el 11 de enero de 2020 se anunció la
primera muerte por kobe 19 tomó ocho
meses llegar al primer millón de
fallecidos y menos de cuatro superar el
umbral de los dos millones
si bien la lucha contra la pandemia es
global las brechas entre naciones ricas
y pobres han quedado más que nunca en
evidencia
wolf las principales economías del mundo
tienen una responsabilidad especial sin
embargo y estamos viendo un vacío de
vacunas las vacunas están llegando
rápidamente a los países de ingresos
altos mientras que los más pobres del
mundo no tienen ninguna la ciencia está
teniendo éxito pero la solidaridad está
fallando
felix se estima que más de 35 millones
de dosis de vacunas han sido
administradas en el mundo según la
universidad de oxford países como israel
eeuu o reino unido ya han inyectado a
millones de personas al menos con una
primera dosis mientras que muchas
naciones gravemente afectadas las
inmunizaciones aún no despegan motivo
por el cual la o ms advierte que la
inmunidad de rebaño a nivel global no se
alcanzará en 2021
los expertos han alertado que el
continuo aumento tanto en los contagios
como en las muertes se debe a que las
sociedades están bajando la guardia y
fallando en romper las cadenas de
contagio
y si es muy fácil echarle la culpa a la
variante y decir que el virus es el
responsable infortunadamente también
ocurre por lo que no hemos hecho y
tenemos que ser capaces de aceptar
nuestra responsabilidad tanto
individualmente como en comunidades como
gobiernos con él y todos millones de
fallecidos llega cuando los gobiernos
del mundo concentran sus esfuerzos en
intentar contener la llegada de nuevas
variantes del virus más contagiosas a
sus territorios para los expertos el
temor se centra en que si los fármacos
no se distribuyen de manera más
equitativa
esto podría darle tiempo al virus para
mutar lo suficiente como para reducir la
efectividad de las vacunas